yeah I uh I've gotten this to you
yesterday but I figured I'd just I'd
have a whole day of having this this
series haunt my thoughts and my dream
last night was not a good night's sleep
[Music]
so Dahmer monster the Jeffrey Dahmer
story is another Jeffrey Dahmer story
with the weirdest title ever Dahmer
monster Dahmer want to just call it the
Jeffrey anyhow seems redundant but it is
another telling of the Jeffrey Dahmer
story and I know what you're thinking
you're like we need another one but how
many times are they going to tell this
guy's story but that's why this is worth
watching and worth talking about because
it's not just another oh hey a look into
the life in Times of Jeffrey Dahmer it's
a Ryan Murphy production you might know
him from American Horror Story An
American Crime Story Fame and I bring
that up because I feel like this Jeffrey
Dahmer Story on Netflix is a culmination
of the two concepts of American Horror
Story and American Crime Story and
that's where the show stands out in
terms of the cast Evan Peters plays
Jeffrey Dahmer gonna get it right out of
the way right now he was absolutely
incredible as Jeffrey Dahmer in this
telling I've seen people be like I hope
he I hope he has counseling and a lot of
friends around him because that must
have been taxing on his psyche when I
first read that it was before I saw this
mini series and I was like oh that's
probably exaggeration then you watch it
you're like yeah
okay I don't disagree I think I liked
about Evan Peter's portrayal of Jeffrey
Dahmer and how this show handled Jeffrey
Dahmer is it did bring a believable
Humanity to the monster that's not to
say empathetic or making excuses for
just in in terms of context you can show
context for something or someone
horrific without making excuses for them
and I felt that's what the show did well
for people who love their true crime
Dives it does have that true crime
insight into the life in Times in the
past of Jeffrey Dahmer the first episode
is tension incarnate what I liked about
the tension was the subtlety of it from
the get-go you can tell this show knows
and recognizes they are dealing with a
real story in which there are real lives
that were affected and continue to be
affected by this monster to this day so
it's not too gratuitous it doesn't show
the dissections as they're happening in
fact a lot of the times when Dahmer is
dissecting bodies or whatnot you hear it
through the walls it shows the neighbor
Glenda Cleveland played by Nissi Nash
also incredible and yeah if Evan Peters
is in the conversation for award time
nisi Nash has to be too I've said before
and I maintained there is a difference
between Gore and horror you can have
horror without Gore and Gore without
horror but Jeffrey Dahmer did was
horrifying you don't need to see it on
camera as it's going down to know that
it happened it is far more interesting
concentrating on his neighbor Glinda
Cleveland and her hearing the sounds and
smelling the horrific smells of decaying
bodies in in the apartment next door
than just you know blood
because Dahmer and we need blood it's
not to say it doesn't show anything
because if you don't show anything you
don't really you don't get a sense of
what Dahmer's doing and it's almost an
injustice at that point there is a fine
line you need to show enough to do the
family's Justice in terms of the horrors
you don't want to show too much to where
it's gratuitous to where now you're
disrespectful it's it's a fine line to
ride I felt this series wrote it very
well and I love the subtlety intention
of that first episode it shows him
cleaning off one of those electric
chicken saws cleaning the blood off you
look around you're like yep sulfuric
acid it's like the prop Department knew
what they had to have in that apartment
I mean the apartment was actually
constructed I've seen layouts of
Dahmer's apartment I'm like that's the
apartment but in terms of subtleties
there's this one moment that I caught
and I was like dude but he goes into his
fridge to get a beer and he just opens
it and closes it at the bottom shelf you
see a head but it doesn't have that
close-up shot while the doors closing of
the head it's just he gets a beer and if
you notice the head and the bottom shelf
you notice it and if you don't you don't
subtlety like that is masterful and it
makes it so much scarier for people who
do notice it if you don't notice it the
audience doesn't really feel like they
lost out on anything still a
horrifyingly tense situation as it is
you don't need to see the head in the
fridge but damn did I mention already
that last night was not a good night's
sleep for me because it wasn't so that
first episode opening up with Glenda
Cleveland in her living room hearing the
sounds of Jeffrey Dahmer I was like oh
this is a very interesting take with for
Jeffrey Dahmer and seeing you through
the eyes of the people around him and
the trailer showed that too then the
next few episodes are pretty much the
life of Jeffrey Dahmer I was like okay
it's a better produced story of Jeffrey
Dahmer but okay I guess that's that's
what we get but I can tell you the exact
episode that elevated this miniseries to
the next level it's episode six it
concentrates on a death victim of
Jeffrey Dahmer named Tony Hughes it
shows his life it shows him hanging out
with his friends he actually does a
really creative thing when he and his
friends are signing and talking all the
Ambi noise goes down it was just a
really good way of getting
into the life of Tony Hughes this whole
episode is about him so when he runs
across Jeffrey Dahmer it's not oh
Jeffrey Dahmer and he's about to kill
another victim it was oh Tony Hughes has
run across Jeffrey Dahmer
and now you're you're pleading for his
life and from that episode on is when
the show largely concentrates on the
people around Jeffrey Dahmer the lives
he destroyed there's a lot of
Destruction that orbits murder and a lot
more victims than those who were
murdered the families around those
people those are victims the loved ones
the friends they're victims I appreciate
this mini-series for that I feel like
this show might set a new standard as to
how to show serial killer stories after
this I was even interested in how this
series showed how the parents dealt with
it because that is a thing I've always
thought about where someone murders
somebody or someone's a serial killer
and there's a lot of conversation around
it
but I remember I I would always think
like how do the parents how do they deal
with that granted is probably not always
in the healthiest way and the show shows
that it's not there's a lot of finger
pointing a lot of blame going around a
lot of internalized blame because there
are things that we're just wired our
brains are wired to process in a normal
healthy way that information's not you
know you have all politician backed out
on a promise maybe they lied Bills suck
oh there's an unexpected bill you know
these are annoyances but they're things
that we know how to deal with because
you know we've lived this long your
son's a serial killer he killed up to 17
people and he ate them it's just there's
no part of your brain there's no part of
a parent's brain that's prepared for
that look in the end this monster
Jeffrey Dahmer series on Netflix I
thought it was really well done it
Chronicles Jeffrey Dahmer's upbringing
in his past in a way that begs to ask
why like why how did this happen but it
does that in a package that also pays
respect to the victims and the families
but it also has a very deep and
interesting conversation about out the
systems that failed his victims it's all
part of a deeper and far more
interesting conversation surrounding
Jeffrey Dahmer in the conversation I've
usually heard which is the serial killer
who ate people in a world where Jeffrey
Dahmer stories are a dime a dozen at
this point I feel like this is one that
does give you something new even if
you're someone who's seen all the other
ones feel like this is still worth
checking out I mean granted it'll haunt
your dreams I mean that in a good way
though doesn't sound very good but I
feel like the subject matter like this
they're one of two possibilities either
gonna haunt your dreams or it's gonna be
forgettable given the choice of the two
I'll take the former over the ladder the
one thing I will say is sometimes it
time jumps you know you're dealing with
the present and in the past time jumps a
couple times to where it was almost it
was jarring I was like wait what what
year are we in all right so Dahmer
monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]